let's start today with the economy is a
massive recession coming is question one
question two is if so or if not what if
anything should you or I or anybody else
be doing about it uh we're seeing
increasingly hyperbolic predictions
about just a massive Global and American
recession coming is one coming I have no
idea I'll if you're waiting for me to
give my opinion I have absolutely no
idea whether a massive recession is
coming but really neither does anybody
else so let's talk through it and
explain first of all as a general
reality
humans aren't good at making economic
predictions just not good and secondly
when there are so many predictions
floating around someone is predicting
everything somebody is bound to be right
just by chance so you've got all the
people predicting a recession in a week
and then in a month and then in six
months and over the next 12 to 18 months
over the next two years or no recession
it's all going to be great somebody's
bound to get it right just by chance and
by the fact that we have 330 million
people in the United States many of whom
are making economic predictions that's
number two number three
predicting Doom and Gloom and recessions
generally gets more clicks and gets you
invited onto more television programs
and gets more articles written about
your predictions so it's important to
understand the bias to sensationalism
and zooming out and saying hey you know
what
I don't know what's going to happen over
the next two years but over the next 30
the market will probably return an
average of seven percent per year like
it always has that's not a particularly
titillating and exciting prediction and
that's not going to get you booked on
too many television programs so that's
another important thing to understand
the bias to sensationalism and a bias to
negative predictions and then number
four and this may be the most important
thing unless something changes with the
way our economy works there's always a
recession coming eventually so if you
predict a recession for long enough or
over a long enough period of time
at some point you're going to be right
because unless something changes and we
have no more recessions and again as
we've talked about before recessions are
sort of part of a capitalist economy if
you keep predicting recessions at some
point you're going to be right now let's
get into the specifics there are people
who have been predicting a recession a
massive recession since 2012 since 2014
since 2016. and the truth is that the
economy has been pretty good for most of
that time we had this covid collapse
which lasted like six weeks markets
collapsing unemployment rate increasing
and then it recovered relatively quickly
they've been wrong but if they keep
predicting it at some point they might
end up being right
so now let's get to a question about
numbers and data are there good or
accurate predictors of when a recession
is coming if we look back in history and
the answer is there are a handful of
indicators that do indeed seem to point
to the economy being quote good or quote
bad and these are terms that don't
really mean anything unless we decide to
Define them a little bit better so what
can we say about the indicators the
first thing is when you start seeing a
steady rise in job losses and a surge in
the unemployment rate that can be a good
indicator of a coming recession now we
don't have that at this point in time if
we look at job creation you see that it
actually looks pretty good you see if
you're looking at the screen here on the
left side of your screen is the
unemployment rate and on the right side
of the screen is job creation we had a
big spike in the unemployment rate
during the beginning of covid and we had
a big drop in
um uh payrolls at the at that exact same
time and then since then we've seen the
unemployment rate go down and remain
pretty low and we've seen uh payrolls
increase and remain uh quite frankly
quite high now is it possible is it
possible that you would see a recession
despite a solid employment situation
anything is possible but it's not the
way it tends to go historically
um I think I had one other chart here ah
yes so this is uh just all a little bit
of a more zoomed in look at the
unemployment rate and as you can see if
you go back a long way there's been sort
of like this range and we're well within
the range that we've seen for many many
decades at this point in time okay so
what other indicators could we look at
that might signal that a recession is
coming well another one is a decline in
GDP and when you look at GDP you do see
that in that start of 2020 there's this
little Decline and it's little
historically speaking but it was
significant at the time and you see that
um real GDP went down and then it has
gone relatively back to normal and
increased and there were a couple little
dips there but GDP really looks pretty
unremarkable so that's not an indicator
historically that a recession is coming
another indicator that historically has
been sometimes predictive of a recession
is retail sales and when you look at
retail sales and in fact we can look at
it um maybe over the 25-year period or
even a 10-year period you see that
retail sales are actually pretty okay
year over year there was this big
decline again that so much of this
mirroring what was going on with covet
very large decline in retail sales at
the beginning of 2020 March April and
then there was this very big income
increase looks like roughly when exactly
was that that was
um sort of like middle of 2021 and
retail sales are pretty unremarkable so
we're just not seeing the indicators
that are normally predictive of a
recession signal that a recession is
coming now what are the differences the
differences are
inflation
um although it is declining and I
believe will continue to decline has
been high historically high for about a
year or even a little bit more could
that alone even in the context of all of
these other indicators looking fine
could that maybe point to a recession
maybe but again it's if things are
changing if the circumstances that point
to a recession are different now than
they were in the past so we'll go we're
going to have to wait and see
now a really important thing to think
about at the individual level is what
should you be doing what should I be
doing what should individuals be doing
if we believe a recession is coming to
be best prepared they're really the
things that we should be doing all the
time so first and foremost do you have
an emergency fund when we think about an
emergency fund we're usually talking
about a thousand dollars so that if an
unexpected expense above and beyond your
normal monthly expenses comes up you
don't have to put it on a high interest
credit card or borrow money thousand
dollar emergency fund if you don't have
it in particular if you think a
recession is coming you should work to
establish that number two understand
your health insurance limits so that you
know if I have unexpected medical bills
and medical bills are often unexpected
what is the most that I might have to go
out of pocket so this means
understanding your deductible and
understanding your maximum out of pocket
number three paying down high interest
debt for two reasons number one paying
fifteen twenty percent interest on a
credit card is
um a very bad financially that's an
extraordinarily High interest rate and
if you can avoid paying that um you you
want to avoid paying that and number two
uh on the the high interest debt if you
believe a recession is or may be coming
and if you want to have as much
Financial flexibility as possible you
want to have credit available on those
credit cards and every dollar you can
pay off freeze up a dollar if indeed you
had no choice but to start charging
things in a future recession and then
number four
try to establish that four to six month
reserve of monthly expenses so in an
ideal world you would figure out what
are my monthly expenses you would
multiply by four or ideally six or if
you want to be you know have an extra
cushion and it's not possible for many
people by nine and have somewhere
between four and six or even nine months
of expenses in the bank so if your
income went to zero for that period of
time you would still be able to pay your
monthly expenses uh this is the type of
stuff we typically talk about on the
Pacman Finance channel so if any of this
is interesting we have this whole other
channel you can find it at youtube.com
pacmanfinance and if you go through uh
the topics we've covered you see that
most of the things I've mentioned are
listed as individual videos paying off
debt uh building a budget
um
etc etc so check that out at youtube.com
pacmanfinance if it is interesting to
you